[Musique]
bonsoir c'est l'heure de public
d'auditions publiques pardon sur public
sénat lcp assemblée nationale et figaro
live nous sommes ensemble comme tous les
lundis pendant une heure en direct pour
débattre pour confronter les idées
surtout qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à
dire en ce moment autour de la réforme
des retraites évidemment et on accueille
ce soir laurent pietra chez ski bonsoir
mon secrétaire d'état aux retraites tout
nouveau puisque ça fait quarante jours
que vous êtes à ce poste vous avez
succédé à jean paul delevoye
on va au cours de cette émission
accueillir différentes personnes qui
vont se succéder sur ce plateau mes
consoeurs des chaînes parlementaires qui
vous poseront quelques questions vous
aurez droit aussi à un débat et des
questions de la part de parlementaires
et puis à la fin d'émission c'est yves
thréard du figaro qui viendra ramassé
tout ça et vous soumettre à son
questionnement à lui et puis évidemment
les questions des téléspectateurs qui
peuvent être envoyés sur figaro live et
que je vous relire est évidemment au fur
et à mesure et dans la mesure du
possible c'est à dire du temps qui nous
est imparti évidemment avant de
commencer une première question je sais
pas si vous avez vu cette lettre elle
vous est pas dessiner les destinées aux
présents de l'assemblée nationale
richard ferrand
ce sont 80 députés qui disent ça suffit
ça va beaucoup trop vite cette réforme
des retraites
elle vient d'être présentée en conseil
des ministres vendredi dès demain la
commission spéciale se réunit on a eu
quatre jours pour étudier le texte
ça suffit faut ralentir le rythme est ce
que vous les comprenez d'abord il n'y a
pas eu quinze jours pour étudier le
texte on y revenir plus précisément sur
les délais puisque vous ça s'organise
dans le cadre de la 5ème république
revenons simplement sur l'historique de
tout cela il ya des nominations de ce
que voulait plus que deux ans déjà je
vais vous répondre
très vite il ya des concertations depuis
plus de deux ans qui ont été menées par
jean paul delevoye pour construire un
système futur dont on va parler ici
j'imagine pendant une heure donc ces
concertations ont été menées et tout le
monde l'a dit on a pris le temps et
ensuite on a légitimement interpellé le
gouvernement en lui disant mais
maintenant il est temps de passer à
l'acte et de proposer un texte c'est ce
que fait le gouvernement dans le cadre
des engagements qui ont été pris par le
premier ministre le 11 décembre devant
le saison donc la question qui peut être
posée à ses députés c est ce qu ils ont
le temps de travail et la réponse est
oui est-ce que
ont déjà vécu des calendriers contraint
similaire la réponse est oui si on
simplement la réforme des retraites de
2014 et bien présentation conseil des
ministres le 18 septembre et commission
des affaires sociales le 30 septembre
commission des affaires sociales c'est
pas de la mise a dit mercredi la
commission spéciale ça comptera en plus
de temps de parole sa contrat il leur
appartiendra d'organiser leur commission
spéciale ça surtout un gros intérêt je
crois à la commission spéciale en tous
les cas c'est le choix des députés de la
majorité de la proposer c'est que ça
permet de réunir toutes les commissions
et de toucher tous les sujets puisque
c'est une transformation très profonde
ce sont 80 députés du gauche je
terminais dessus qui disent même à
richard ferrand nous vous demandons
solennellement de défendre l'honneur de
l'assemblée nationale il faut qu'il
regarde le calendrier qui a été proposé
par une restaurer en 2014 et puis
peut-être d'y assembler les applique
le parti socialiste se posent des
questions qui auraient dû se poser
peut-être en 2014 et ça c est ce qui est
ce que l'honneur de l'assemblée était
mis en cause en 2014 ferait semblant ou
pas et ce qui sera mis en cause en 2020
assurément pas on va accueillir
maintenant thème traduit de public sénat
avril bouchée de lcp assemblée nationale
[Musique]
bonsoir table et avoue la première
question est à qui a beaucoup fait
parler de lui évidemment c'est à dire du
jour a rendu son avis sur votre projet
de loi alors il parle de projections
financières lacunaire d'une perte de
visibilité d'ensemble et il critique les
29 ordonnance qui sont également prévus
déjà ce que vous avez été surpris par
cet avis est ensuite est-ce que vous
allez en tenir compte et ce que vous
allez modifier la loi
je comprends que vous fassiez un
raccourci qui ressemble le plus à la
dépêche afp que à la lecture des 63
pages du compte rendu du conseil d'état
mais moi je m'intéresse aux 63 pages du
compte rendu du conseil d'état haris un
peu plus long que la dépêche afp
c'est surtout un peu plus large j'ai été
surpris quand même delà des semaines je
vais répondre à la question parce que il
ya des éléments d'abord que dit le
conseil d'état au cdh et a dit qu'il
était dans un calendrier deux contre un
on l'a évoqué tout à l'heure donc c'est
une réalité nous avons pris un
engagement de le pré ministre a pris un
engagement et nous le tenons de
présenter ce texte le 24 janvier au
conseil des ministres et puis ensuite
d'être dans une situation d'avoir un
vote avant les municipales pour le
passage à l'assemblée il ya ensuite le
passage au sénat et nous verrons ensuite
la suite de la procédure parlementaire
bon donc il est dans un calendrier
contraint dont acte
et il le dit il dit qu'il aurait
souhaité avoir plus de temps oui et en
même temps il réunit son assemblée
générale le conseil d'état et il valide
99 pour soit 99% du texte qui a été
présenté et il dit laquelle j ai
président je vais rendre et la quasi
totalité la quasi totalité des éléments
du texte plus de 99% a été validé par le
conseil d'état donc c'est ça qu'il faut
retenir
et ensuite et ensuite je vais revenir
sur votre question il répond tout c'est
plus simple est ce que est ce que vous
envisagez terme et écouter les specs
budgétaire c'est très simple il y a 29
ordonnance elle laisse de l'espace au
dialogue social ou sais que je défends
ce dialogue social je les réclamer quand
j'étais député je vais pas m'élever
contre lorsque je suis au gouvernement
il ya de la place pour le dialogue
social c'est la conférence de
financement au prix
ça fait retrouver ce qu'on a m ensuite
en dur dans la loi à chaque fois que
cela sera possible et side opeti
notamment l'avantagé de l'ordonnancement
j'en ai déjà débattu à l'assemblée
andolsheim modifié par valence vous dit
brigitte mais les ordonnances est très
simple il ya une habilitation c'est à
dire on détermine le domaine où l'état
le gouvernement pardon peut s'exprimer
et va s'exprimer et ensuite à une
ratification où on vient dire au
gouvernement le parlement s'exprimer dit
d'accord ou pas d'accord donc le moins
qu'on puisse dire c'est que le parlement
est respecté et qui avait alors agi
juste une rampe y être un chef qui quand
même le conseil d'état qui met un bémol
quand même c'est pas forcément
bienvenues le conseil d'état aurait même
moi je trouve qu'il faut dire quand même
il faut respecter il faut respecter
l'instant mais vous devez avoir un avis
je le ferai mais je suis en train de
vous le donner librement il est pas tout
à fait aligner moi je ne suis pas un
coup dur c'est pas pour dire que le
conseil d'état s'exprime en dix ans
j'aurais voulu avoir plus de temps on
sait qu'il a dû s'exprimer en trois
semaines
on sait qu'il avait l'idée 99% du texte
à précède le conseil constitutionnel
vous avez pas peur que mon parti ou une
partie de la loi en tout cas soit
retoquée après la seule partie sur
lequel le conseil d'état parce que il
faut être factuel difficulté c'est je
comprends on essaye de faire des
raccourcis parce qu'on va aller vite
mais il faut être factuel pour ça que je
vous ai parlé des 63 pages
qu'est ce qui dit conseil d'état il se
pose la question de l'obligation pour le
gouvernement d'avoir une loi
pluriannuelle de programmation en
matière de rémunération des enseignants
oui nous assumons le gouvernement assume
de faire un geste très clair vis-à-vis
des enseignants et des chercheurs et de
m dès le début ne tiendra pas le fait
qu'il faille revalorisée passant des
salaires et qu'il faille regarder pour
que on est un niveau de votre aide qui
soit comparable pour les enfants ça ne
changera pas ce sera bien dans la loi
mais ça sera dans la loire alors agnès
buzyn a clairement déclaré hier que le
gouvernement remet très probablement ce
sont ses mots probablement l'âge pivot
dans le texte si la conférence de
financement n'aboutit pas est ce que
cette prise de parole c'est une façon de
mettre la pression sur les partenaires
sociaux sur les syndicats ses prises de
parole c'est juste qu'elle répond agnès
l'usl amitié et solidarité bien santé
aux questions qui lui seront posées
enfin on compte pas lui faire grief de
répondre aux questions qui seront posées
c'est précieux la première réunion ils
ont fait ils vont poser la question à
ministre responsable et c'est le cas de
tous les ministres à savoir ce qui va se
passer si il n'y arrive on n'arrive pas
à produire un accord au sein de la
conférence de financement les ministres
vont vous répondre
l'engagement du premier ministre et du
gouvernement sur le fait de prendre nos
responsabilités mais nous les prendrons
à la lumière des débats moi je crois
nous les prendrons la lumière des débats
qui ont été qui seront organisées par
jour jacquemart est dans le cadre de la
conférence de financement est déjà pas
y'a pas ici de choses cachées
vous connaissez mon sentiment est celui
du gouvernement nous pensons que l'âge
d'équilibré était une bonne façon à la
fois de créer de nouveaux droits mais
aussi d'assurer la robustesse du système
par répartition où je le rappelle les
cotisations servent à payer les pensions
classe et bien une épée de damoclès qui
la faisait sur l'ensemble des
négociations une fois qu'on a deux choix
c'est à dire où on pratique la langue de
bois et vous nous dites il ya de
l'espace pour le dialogue social où on
est transparent avec vous et vous le dis
si l'épée de damoclès moi je ne crois
pas je fonctionne pas comme ça moi je
fais confiance à la démocratie sociale
je me suis battu pour qui les spas spas
démocratie sociale il ya de l'espace par
démocratie sociale j'ai confiance dans
les partenaires sociaux et je sais
qu'ils seront capables de produire fin
avril quelque chose qu'on mettra en dur
et qui assurera l'équilibré de notre
système
oui lille 27 ses partenaires sociaux
seront tous autour de la table pour
cette conférence de financement je pense
évidemment la cgt et force ouvrière
je l'espère je ne sais pas je peux pas
me prononcer pour la cgt ou force
ouvrière jeu les pennois je vois je les
labels
écoutez je pense que jean jacques maret
tu fais le travail du sexe et j'en est
mare et qui connaît bien les retraites
parfois à l'agirc a fait le travail sur
le fait que la cgt ou fo viendrait où ne
viendrait pas écoutez moi je crois que
les organisations syndicales qui le
souhaitent
viendront après je ne peux pas répondre
à la place de la cgt ce soir je montre
que je suis pas mandaté par elle pour
faire des communiqués sur le sujet
laurent berger était à votre place la
semaine dernière il disait que pour
apaiser un peu la situation
il faudrait sans doute se donner un
petit peu plus de temps est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à revoir le
landrier qui est prévue aujourd'hui pour
cette réforme bon moi j'entends les
remarques qui peuvent être faites sur le
temps le gouvernement a pris les
engagements c'est moi je trouve ça bien
de tenir ses engagements
j'ai un engagement politique très récent
pourquoi beaucoup de femmes et d'hommes
se sont engagés en politique à dire pas
que à la république on marche pas
beaucoup c'est vrai parce que on en
avait un peu en tant que citoyen assez
de voir un écart entre ce que déclarait
les politiques ce qui était en
responsabilité est ce qu'il faisait
eh bien écoutez moi je pense qu'en la
matière le gouvernement des lois
philippe est exemplaire il dit il y aura
une conférence des financements nous
espérons le faire dans un lieu qui soit
neutre où il y aura une animation qui
permettra à chacun de s'exprimer c'est
ce que j'allais m'arrête et ce sera le
cas où ces hommes avec un temps qui est
celui jusqu'au mois d'avril pour
construire une réponse jeudi edouard
philippe aussi ses adeptes voilà
adoption en juillet ça ça changera pas
ce sera adoptée en juillet et saint
laurent-bergé quand ils perdent le
quadrillé dit éventuellement après
juillet 1 septembre novembre laissant
les gens temps est ce que c est ce que
c'est la porte est ouverte ou pas ça en
temps cela nous nous respectons le
calendrier sur lequel nous nous sommes
engagés au donnant du temps mais le
temps il est dans le calendrier changera
pas prêt je ne vois pas qu'est jeu
envers j'ai voulu dit bah non ce sera
dans un an mais moi je dis beaucoup de
choses à laurent berger que à quelques
jeux croisé avec qui je peux disputer
qui vous savez j'entends bien qu'il ait
des attentes en la matière moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'il est 8 et
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux
le temps de construire une réponse santé
je vois qu'ils ont apprécié sur la
réforme notamment la baisse de
cotisations des très hauts cadres dans
la réforme tous ceux qui gagnent plus de
10000 euros par mois ne perd quasiment
plus de cotisations à partir de 10
millions à sa sera 2 8% au lieu de 26%
jusqu'à 10000 euros
ça a été chiffré le coût le coup il va
être de 3,7 milliards d'euros pendant 15
ans c'est ce que dit l'agirc arrco est
ce que aujourd'hui on peut se le
permettre ce trou de 55 milliards
d'euros au total pour regarder ce sujet
là c'est vous avez je vous remercie de
l'exactitude de vos propos souligné
d'abord que au delà de trois plafonds de
la sécurité sociale
pour faire simple au delà euros par mois
de revenus eh bien nous allons continuer
tous ceux qui sont concernés vont
continuer
à payer une cotisation de 2 81% je
voulais le truc c'est que je vaux bien
fonctionné pas raccourci tout le temps
mais je veux quand même expliquer les
choses je suis venu là pour ça
d'ailleurs
on va le faire grief devant quelle
pédagogie lorsque je vais essayer
d'expliquer votre force et de
ferronnerie
c'est très sain de la question est
simple j'ai répond j'y réponds 2 91 ans
et plus que la cotisation déplafonné
aujourd'hui donc est-ce qu'il ya plus de
solidarité
la réponse c'est oui deuxièmement vous
me dites est ce qu'on va ceux qui ont
des revenus supérieurs à ses 10000 euros
est-ce qu'ils vont cotiser bien ça va
s'éteindre progressivement une quinzaine
d'années et ils vont donc cotiser de
moins en moins au delà de trois plafonds
bien sûr qu'il y aura il y aura un
manque de recettes
voilà matière je voulais mais il y aura
aussi mais il y aura aussi mais c'est
tout l'intérêt de raisonner de façon
dynamique et dans le temps mais il y
aura aussi des pensions en moins à payer
alors moi je veux bien qu'on fasse des
calculs à l'hiver je viens de regarder
quelqu'un données dans un système de
répartition on peut on peut passer du
temps en disant qu est ce qui va se
passer pendant 15 ans moi j'ai une
responsabilité de créer un système
solide et durable
je voudrais également vous dire que ce
système de 3 plafond est un système qui
est où c'est le plus important des pays
de l'osce et des eaux
c'est celui qui va donner la plus belle
couverture sociale à l'ensemble de nos
concitoyens en matière d'assurance
vieillesse et que au delà de trois
plafonds les choses s'éteindront
progressivement
bien sûr que les droits qu'ils ont été
constitués seront honorés et il y aura
de moins en moins de cotisations mais il
y aura aussi il faut regarder les choses
ont tendance yale dont on nous dit
durera moins de cotisations demain bien
sûr mais il y aura surtout moins de
pension après demain et donc ceux qui
font ces calculs serait sans doute bien
inspiré à la fois de regarder le manque
de cotisation mais aussi de dire combien
de pension ne sera pas à payer autour de
cela et donc c'est ça l'équilibré des
shows that dans un exercice contre 1
puisque vous
vous dites que les dépenses concernant
les retraites ne devront pas dépasser 14
% du produit intérieur brut de la brute
de la richesse nationale tout simplement
pourquoi cette contrainte est ce que
vous mettez pas là les pieds et poings
liés
il faut se poser vous savez moi j'ai
découvert avec mon mandat de député il
ya deux ans et demi le conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui
représentait l'assemblée nationale
jusqu'à 40 jours comme vous le rappeliez
tout à l'heure où c'est le conseil
d'orientation des retraites c'est un
organisme indépendant où il ya des
représentants de tous les partenaires
sociaux et justement je vais vous
répondre et dont le conseil
d'orientation des retraites qui n'est
pas un repère de spécialistes
thatchérien oui et c'est pas des les
ultralibéraux qui sont réglées dans un
think tank
ce sont les représentants des
partenaires sociaux eh bien vous savez
c'est un truc incroyable et bien dans le
conseil d'orientation des retraites
toutes les perspectives sont faites en
pourcentage du pib soit et retraite
donc pourquoi parce que c'est une bonne
chose qui vous permet c'est une notion
qui me permet de voir les choses étaient
attendus ok mais 14% ses bas et c'est
contraignant non c'est pas du tout et
c'est cette richesse et on est en europe
le 3 1 3e part du pib la plus importante
donc c'est pas du tout c'est très très
haut donc je pense que vous êtes mal
informé en allemagne c'est 11%
donc il faut que vous soyez fous les
traits au père c'est justement vous
voulez qu'on fasse en sorte parce que
non mais moi ça me voir l'élite
mais 4% à 14% vous contraignez et ça
veut dire aussi que si par hasard les
dépenses de retraite augmente vous ne
pourrez plus les payer ou alors il
faudra baisser les pensions non s'est il
faut rester je comprends qu'il puisse y
avoir des inquiétudes mais je sais bien
et puis je vous remercie de l'est de les
donner à voir comme ça au clair il faut
être objectif il faut dire les choses
concitoyens j invite d'ailleurs tous
ceux qui nous suivent et qui nous
regardent aujourd'hui d'aller sur le
site du conseil d'orientation des
retraites
ils vont sur internet ils vont regarder
le site de conseil d'orientation des
retraites idées verront quoi ils y
verront que depuis dix ans depuis dix
ans nous avons 2 millions de retraités
en plus et que nous avons une
augmentation de la pension moyenne de 20
% de la pension qui est versée et que
tout cela continue à se faire avec une
part de pib relativement constante 13 7
13%
c'est incontestable s'est fait par le
fameux conseil d'orientation des
retraites donc nous avons
évoquer les choses tout à l'heure donc
votre question je l'entends mais les
faits démontrent le contraire c'était
assez simple suffit de le faire bah
c'est pas pareil c'est celle du conseil
davantage ouverts sur ce texte
et il y en aura dans votre groupe en ses
cadres a beaucoup dans les oppositions
mais dans votre groupe possible
peut-être sur les les hausses de
cotisations pour les hauts salaires
peut-être sur le sort des femmes
peut-être sur la retraite minimum à 100
% du smic que réclame laurent berger en
tout cas est ce que vous allez écouter
ces parlementaires et quel rôle il y
aura pour les députés le rôle des
députés il est connu au vème république
ils ont un rôle d'amender la loi et puis
la beauté il peut donc y compris
d'ailleurs sur le canton travail des
annonces que je suis bien placé pour
vous dire que quand on a des ordonnances
et quand on était à porter et que on a
cela dans son tête on passe deux fois
devant l'assemblée
comme je vous l'expliquais tout à
l'heure est il que il ya des débats qui
sont très importants alors quel peut
être le rôle
quel peut être le rôle écoutez il ya des
lignes politiques qui vont s'exprimer
c'est vraisemblable j'étais député ya
quelques jours je ne m'a pas échappé que
il y avait des groupes différents et
l'assemblée des temps ils font
d'ailleurs je livre en courant les
rencontres et je suis attentif à ce que
disent les uns les autres parce que
c'est moi ma volonté et c'est celle du
gouvernement c'est pas de mener à bien
une bataille parlementaire politique
c'est de construire un socle un socle de
solidarité
quelque chose qui soit fondateur entre
tous les citoyens quelque chose qui qui
nous parle de notre solidarité entre les
générations qui soit mais écoutez qu'est
ce que c'est qu'être sourd et les
amendements si c'est être dans un dans
une construction qui nous permet d'avoir
un système universel par répartition par
point avec des précipitations à des prix
bas écouter on va voir ce qu'on nous
propose
on verra ce que vous proposez si vous
nous parlez beaucoup des gagnants mais
parmi les perdants n'y at il pas avant
tout et d'aller salariés du secteur
privé dont la retraite va être calculée
à partir de toute la carrière et non
plus les 25 meilleures années
donc c'est une question aussi un très
intéressant j'ai eu à plusieurs reprises
alors d'abord un point extrêmement
facile objectif que tout le monde peut
vérifier encore une fois sur internet
bien la retraite complémentaire mais qui
fait plus de 60 % de la pension de
retraite des cadres et près de 40 % de
la pension de retraite donc c'est
significatif c'est pas un petit morceau
de la retraite de ma pension la retraite
complémentaire des salariés en france
70% des actifs c'est significatif allez
aujourd'hui par point par répartition
calculée sur l'intégralité de la
carrière
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire où
l'essai de se faire peur en disons vous
imaginez que les partenaires sociaux qui
gèrent depuis des dizaines d'années la
jirs caron on in en place un dispositif
qui vise à générer une interrogation non
non c'est pas complémentaires ces 60
pour cent mille région de deuxième vingt
deuxième on va faire un tout petit peu
de technique mais très peu parce que je
veux faire on dé vous en dire c'est trop
technique
bon le montant de la pension le montant
de la pension on vous prend ce qu'on
appelle les salaires portés au compte
vos salaires de référence dans le
système actuel de ses 25 meilleures
années
et vous savez qu'on vous vouliez divise
par deux pour calculer mon trouve haute
tension donc ça veut dire quoi que les
grands mathématiciens en herbe qui
viennent nous expliquer parce que c'est
facile et c'est bien de faire un effet
de manche commence en disant c'est
facile à comprendre que 25 meilleures
années c'est plus intéressant que la
totalité de la carrière mais ils ont
peut-être oublié de vous raconter que
ces 50 parce qu'il fallait reporter au
compte qu'ils ont peut-être oublié de
vous dire aussi que c'est plafonné et
que du coup ceux qui ont justement des
rémunérations très importante en fin de
carrière qui sont à 2,3 passes ne sont
pas prises en compte dans le cadre de la
retraite de base
bref c'est facile d'avoir des positions
un peu toute leur vie ils risquent d'y
perdre à dont ceux qui sont là parce
qu'ils ont un vrai d'évolution ils vont
y gagner
excusez moi je veux préciser je veux
qu'ils sont persique au début et qui au
bout de 10 ans 100 euros de plus par
exemple elles vont ils gagner aussi
avoir gagné aussi bien sûr moins
qu'aujourd'hui
- non je vais gagner beaucoup plus
qu'aujourd'hui la norme puisque c'est
les 25 meilleurs gardiens quand même eh
ben on voit enfin moi j'ai fait la
simulation aujourd'hui je veux quand
même travaillé jusqu'à un certain âge
pour pouvoir y gagner je vois quand même
par exemple de 62 à quasiment 65 ans
j'ai vu que je ne faisais qui perdent
alors c'est intéressant
il est temps de me trouver
moi je prends tout à fait qu'est ce
qu'on a sur l'outil réforme tirer
retraite points vous pourrez faire je
suis un peu d'eux c'était en même temps
plus un tel monde puisse se connecter
on a des parcours type et c'est vrai que
c'est ce que vous avez dit c'est pas
purement votre parcours mais mais mais
mais voilà vous avez là 70 cas à peu
près il y en aura un peu plus en fin de
semaine on va en mettre
130 en ligne au plus vite mais
effectivement dans ces parcours type
qu'est ce qu'on voit on voit que la
réalité la réalité c'est que aujourd'hui
il faut vous si vous rentrez dans la vie
active à 22 ans ce qui est le cas moyen
constaté qu'on fasse ou pas des études
avec la réforme touraine voter en 2014
dont on parlait tout à l'heure au
conseil des ministres le 18 septembre
commission de 30 septembre et bien dont
on parlait tout à l'heure
eh bien il faut travailler 43 ans donc
ce qu'on vous dit dans les simulateurs
c'est que la réalité de 2035 et actes et
qu'ils aient voté y compris à l'époque
c'est une majorité je crois que parti
socialiste qu'il a voté
et bien il faut travailler jusqu'à 65
ans nous ce qu'on vous dit c'est qu'avec
l'âge déquilibre à partir de 64 ans
c'est neutre et la plupart du temps au
delà de 65 ans vous avez une dynamique
très significatif sur le montant de
votre pension en moyen de plus pour ce
que j'ai mais pour ce qui est du système
universel qui sera en place en 2037
la loi dit qu'il y aura effectivement on
distingue la partie court terme
l'ajustement voilà et très précises sur
les petites retraites la retraite
minimum que vous souhaitez fixé à 1000
euros
si on prend par exemple 1000 euros par
mois si on prend un agriculteur qui
gagne 450 euros par mois est ce qu'on
peut imaginer qu'il aura une retraite
annie l'euro alors qu'est ce qu'on a
qu'est ce qu'on a mis en place là il ya
un premier point 2022 donc on n'est pas
on n'est pas en 2037 2022 retraite
minimale pension minimale à 1000 euros
pour une carrière complète au smic 85%
du smic c'est me leroux seront portés à
85% du smic en 2025
et lorsque nous sommes dans le système
futur 2037
c'est sur une carrière qu'on
qu est ce qu une carrière complète on le
redit ses quarante trois ans comme je
les dis depuis le vote
q depuis le vote de la loi 2014 marisol
touraine
mais c'est surtout et c'est ce que nous
allons proposer le fait que cela puisse
se faire dès on à travailler 50 heures
par mois donc pour répondre à votre
question ça veut dire que quelqu'un qui
l'équivalent de 50 heures smic pour être
très précis l'équivalent de 50 heures
smic donc quelqu'un qui se serait juste
rémunéré l'exemple d'un agriculteur
parce qu'il ne peut pas se prendre plus
sur son exploitation mais ça peut être
vrai aussi les commerçants les artisans
à hauteur de 50 au smic bénéficiera
effectivement de 85% du smic c'est un
dollar au titre donc plus que ça 80
associations disent plus que cette
dynamique vous ai pas envie que j'étais
sur le débat parlementaire ce que vous
vous attendez à des heures difficiles
surtout pour vous qui venez d'arriver
sur le banc du gouvernement
est ce que vous espérez par exemple le
soutien du premier ministre qu'ils
viennent sur les bancs de l'hémicycle
pour soutenir la réforme des retraites
on va écouter l'engagement du premier
ministre il est total sur sur cette
réforme n'y a pas de débat
nous sommes ensemble nous sommes une
équipe gouvernementale nous travaillons
ensemble
après vous poser la question est ce que
j'ai envie d'avoir le premier ministre à
côté de moi avait coûté il est à côté de
moi ou jusqu'à coûté lui en tous les cas
pendant les questions au gouvernement à
chaque fois que c'est nécessaire et
utile
il ya je vous dis très franchement j'ai
lu ministre du tutelle qui est agnès
buzyn fait la dignité solidarité de la
santé
elle prendra toute sa place dans ce
débat et moi je serais très heureux d'y
accueillir vous savez j'ai un grand
plaisir d'être à l'assemblée j'ai
compris que ça pouvait faire l'objet
d'un peu du bruissement médiatiques
parfois tout c'est toutes ces débats
libres ministre et a été à sa tâche
moi je le vois très clairement très
engagé sur ce sujet comme sur tous les
autres et je s'il souhaite revenir à
l'assemblée il y sera le belize et coûté
très franchement si vous voulez me faire
réagir sur les bruissements médiatique
vous aurez pas grand chose de ma part
parce que ce serait moi je suis venu
parler des retraites donc oui mais les
retraites c'est pour les mini ses
prémices et avec quoi
je vois le pré ministre à chaque fois
que c'est nécessaire je les revues
encore en fin de semaine dernière
je peux vous dire qu'il est totalement à
sa tâche de chef du gouvernement il n'y
a aucune ambiguïté à mathieu bien merci
brigitte merci tap
on va maintenant accueillir les deux
parlementaires qui vont vous poser leurs
questions à un e bon plus précise encore
parce qu'il sent coeur de la machine
vous allez vous être encore plus vous
allez voir vous allez voir pour soir
monique lubin soir sénatrice ps des
landes membre du conseil d'orientation
des retraites
oui me connaissait bien sûr le
remplissage est ce qui vous a eu
l'occasion déjà de travailler avec lui
et bonsoir aurélien pradié vous êtes
député les républicains du lot et
secrétaire général du parti de christian
jacob
on va commencer par vous money cuba
voulait poser une question d'abord sur
la chp et vous oui monsieur le ministre
dans la première mouture du texte il y
avait un âge pivot à 64 ans
et puis cet âge pivot a disparu alors on
essaie de nous faire croire qu'il a
disparu définitivement
il a disparu dans la mesure où les
partenaires sociaux trouvent avant le 30
avril 12 milliards d'euros excusez moi
du peu
déjà je n'y crois pas beaucoup mais il
n'a pas disparu en fait puisque à partir
de 2030 cette il y aura ce que vous
appelez un âge d équilibre et ça ne sera
non plus 64 ans mais ça sera 65 ans moi
tout simplement monsieur le ministre
j'ai quand même l'impression que tout ça
ça s'appelle un recul de l'âge de la
retraite et que vous ne l'assumé pas bon
la sénatrice qu'on en plus c'est vrai
qu'on se connaît pas ce qu on s'est
côtoyé au conseil d'orientation des
retraites et je sais votre intérêt pour
le sujet mais vous avez bien d'autres
questions mais je vais gérer plus je
leur réponds que non mais je réponds
très tranquillement
et parce que sur le fond j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya une partie de la
réponse on peut être on pourrait
d'accord mais je peux être un essai à la
sur le fond il ya eu une demande des
partenaires sociaux de dire le retour à
l équilibre que le gouvernement demande
avec ce besoin de financement de 12
milliards qui étaient mis en évidence
par le corps sont pour une hypothèse
moyenne et on restera sur l'hypothèse
moyenne sur le fond nous on souhaite à
dire comment nous voyons les choses au
niveau des partenaires sociaux nous
voulons prendre la main c'est hélas la
demande de laurent berger le
gouvernement il ya répondu favorablement
et cette demande a été clair ils ont
mais nous nous sommes d'accord pour
prendre nos responsabilités mais nous ne
voulons pas et c'était l'objet d'une des
question qui a été posée tout à l'heure
nous ne voulons pas le faire sous une
contrainte qui serait explicité dans la
loi me dit tu viens vous dit est ce que
c'est une fin un recul et la jeune garde
a également retiré de la loi donc le
terme
peu importe mais on dirait le
gouvernement à bouger 1 il a retiré de
la loi les dispositions de l'equilibre
court terme et il a laissé et je suis
sur la deuxième partie vos questions les
éléments de l'equilibre long terme pour
une raison simple c'est que moi je crois
je crois que le gouvernement aussi
assurément au dialogue social et que si
on veut 50 formations de société il faut
le faire aussi on s'appuie donc c'est
soit sur équilibre ses 65 ans ne s'est
pas 65 ans l'âge des qui les propose un
questionnaire va je vous réponds allait
d'abord l'âge de départ moyen à la
retraite aujourd'hui c'est 63,4
justement qu'est-ce que nous avons mise
et vous faites référence je pense aux
études d'impact
voilà qu'est ce que nous avons mis dans
l'étude d'impact
nous avons mis ce que j'ai essayé
d'expliquer son doute pas c'est bien
parce que la question revient tout à
l'heure c'est que l'âge moyen constaté
de rentrer dans la vie active ses 22 ans
que le dispositif touraine amènera tout
le monde à voir durée d'activité 43 ans
22 + 43 gars de 65 kg cinq ans donc il
appartiendra aux partenaires sociaux à
la gouvernance de proposer au
gouvernement un hd qui libre et nous
verrons ce que cela serein mais je crois
que c'est cela qu'il faut entendre les
cubains
vous encadrez déjà très nettement cette
tâche d'équilibrer les partenaires
sociaux je pense seront les dindons de
la farce
ils n'auront pas vraiment le choix ils
seront tellement encadrée et vous leur
ferez en plus porter une responsabilité
qui ne doit pas leur incombe et et puis
sur l'étude d'impact vous considérez des
gens qui commencent à travailler à 22
ans qui travaille pendant 43 ans qui
n'ont aucun accident professionnel
pendant ces quarante trois ans coûte et
ça ça existe dans un monde merveilleux
un monde merveilleux que je ne je ne
connais pas par contre tous les gens qui
commencent à travailler avant 22 ans et
il y en a beaucoup
cela ils vont subir une double peine
parce qu'ils vont travailler très
longtemps que l'âge de 62 ans restera
bien inscrit dans la loi mais que de
toute façon comme ils auront les
retraites les plus faibles
ils n'auront pas le choix de partir à 62
ans ils devront attendre l'equilibre
l'âge déquilibre parce qu'ils ne
pourront pas se permettre de voir
baisser leur retraite de 5 10 ou 15% et
tout ça ce sont des choses que vous
occultez complètement vous occultez est
ce que je peux oui je joue demain
peut-être un petit petit à un éclairage
de réponse mais peut-être qu'on ne
serait pas encore d'accord en fait c'est
justement parce que nous voulons lutter
contre les petites pensions et donjons
donné à la majorité des français
un niveau de pension qui soient
satisfaisants que nous avons proposé le
sujet qui a été abordé tout à l'heure
c'est un minima de mieux euros et une
dynamique de 85% du smic je rappelle que
le smic est en dynamique tous les ans et
qu'il est réévaluée et donc ça veut dire
que le minimum de pension sera réévaluée
mais justement moi je vous parle de cela
ils sont et cette prestation dans le
fusil gens sont 50000 tous les ans avant
de leur retraite au minimum contributif
et donc c'est très important qu'on soit
quand il ressemble à ça et je je pense
parce que je connais votre je veux j'en
dirai pas plus mais je connais je crois
que votre attachement et solidarité que
ce soit là on peut au moins être
d'accord alors en tout cas en tout cas
aurélien pradié justement voudrais
parler des 1000 euros par mois parce
qu'ils se posent des questions sur la
mise en place exactement de ses 1000
euros par mois oui monsieur le
secrétaire d'état il ya quelques
semaines vous étiez vous étiez députés
et vous avez fait partie de ceux avec
vos collègues qui ont porté comme un
totem cette mesure des 1000 euros
minimum comme étant la mesure de justice
de cette réforme des retraites sûrement
est-ce qu'il vous fallait trouver un
sujet qui permettent de compenser
d'autres formes d'injustice mais
néanmoins nous avons été nombreux à
revenir avec beaucoup d'attention cette
mesure là et beaucoup de nos concitoyens
ont retenu aussi parce que à la fois
vous même comme député mais aussi vos
collègues n'avaient pris aucune
précaution de langage ni même le nom du
gouvernement de l'époque ils ont tous
dit que désormais la retraite minimale
serait de 1000 euros pour tous or au fur
à mesure des débats nous constatons
qu'il ya un ensemble de critères pour
obtenir ces 1000 euros vous parlez de
carrière complète vous l'avait redit et
tout à l'heure et de cotisation au
niveau smic nous avons aujourd'hui plus
de 60% de l'agriculteur qui ne cotisent
pas au niveau speak la question des 50
heures pour évoquer tout à l'heure ni
réglera rien d'ailleurs ce qui veut donc
dire que sur les quelques millions
d'agriculteurs que nous avons
aujourd'hui ceux qui n'auront pas cotisé
au niveau smic ils sont 60% ne seront
pas éligibles aux mille euros il faut
que vous le disiez que les rues d'och et
si comme il vous faut dire clairement
que celles et ceux qui sont déjà en
situation de retraite ne verront pas
d'évolution de leur situation vos
questions et simple est ce que les
agriculteurs qui n'ont pas cotisé au
niveau smic les 60 % dont je vous
parlais auront droit aux mille euros oui
ou non dans les conditions que vous
évoquez tout à l'heure c'est donc la
réponse des deux mais non la réponse est
oui j'ai joué dans la danse et non ses
51 aux énormes et 1,14 à sion
l'équivalent et non mais la plupart
n'ont pas c'est combien de roubia
d'heure travaillons-nous par mois des
fouilles soit 52 des gens donc la
question et non salée pour les gens
c'est équivalent temps plein etp en 250
heures donc vous savez que je voudrais
je pense que le malentendu et dans vos
coureurs comme pour 50 heures par mois
dans le compteur c'est un tiers-temps
donc la question est ce quelqu'un qui
était à 60 % à toucher 85 % de 50 oui
non 50 heures cotiser au niveau smic
nous avons aujourd'hui plus de 40% de
l'agriculteur sur les 50 heures qui n'y
sont pas vous savez comme moi que 100%
nos agriculteurs ne cotisent pas même 50
heures au niveau smic enfin prenez
conscience gibier les revenus des
rigolos
ce qui veut dire nous attendrons les
agriculteurs de ne pas non mais c'est
pas et c'est ça ce n'est pas ce qui est
jugé par cela
c'est un tiers-temps et bien sûr temps
donc ça veut dire que les matignon au
tir tant que nous je suis nous ignorer
même où j'ai fait à beaucamps ligny
passer toutes les animaux chez un
agriculteur vous aimez vraiment
spécialement fait de la vache allaitante
vous cherchez les quand tu dois vous
écoute et qu'on cherche d'ailleurs il
doit un peu de charité vont chercher à
être factuel faux soyons je le suis
alors je suis donc je voulais cette
année en une nuit c'est vrai que ce bois
et autres lettres sur ce sont des
artisans je veux simplement que vous ne
répondiez et que vous le disais aux
français ils sont clairement les
quelques agriculteurs nombre près de 40
% et 60 % qui ne cotisent pas au niveau
smic ni même à 50 eur niveau smic
comment cela seront traités même s'il y
en a seulement quelques milliers vous
devez leur dire que ceux là n'auront pas
droit aux niveaux mille euros que vous
annoncez dites le clairement tout comme
dit clairement que ce que les 2,5
millions de retraités agricoles
aujourd'hui en situation de retraite ne
rompt pas les minéraux aussi je vous
demande simplement de l'éclaircir c'est
pas très compliqué c'est pas très
compliqué où j'essaie juste de vous
répondre mais visiblement vous n'avez
pas envie d'accepter l'appareil et de
dire vous milieu alors les règles y
aurait beaucoup d'agriculteurs ne
valorise pas 50 en un tiers-temps qui je
connaissais pas les stats maintenant des
revenus de l'agriculture
à leurs côtés on avait un truc imaginez
juste imaginer que oui moi je vous fais
pas de procès est-ce que ce soit la
braderie pour faire là on n'est pas ce
que vous dites fort que 100% je vous ai
déjà répondu à la question la réponse
est à partir de 50 ans mick mais pas
d'accord les agriculteurs ou les
commerces dont les abonnements les
femmes nourrissent une bonne moitié ne
verront pas exigé c'est important
d'associer ces composés une bonne moitié
seront gagnés il faut pour saler
l'ouvrir aux femmes qui sont aussi non
mais pas une bonne moitié si vous allez
en 7 45 abidjan van boxmeer donc vous
assure que ce sera vous sur le chiffre
de la tour nationale et on n'a pas
besoin d'aller voir la dynamique la
rémunération des agriculteurs
je pense que vous ne la connaissez pas
assurément jusqu'en 2037
moi non plus d'ailleurs et donc c'est à
dire qu'une fois qu'ils auront bien
construit
il a proposé que cette dynamique de la
femme hurle en changer mais attire tombe
le drame il faut vous soyez un peu
réaliste juste sur l'arrêté wenger un
chiffre que ce que vous avez envie vous
ignorer la réalité de notamment de sept
jours
vous avez vous avez à faire à qui vous
avez pas l'âge de rêve des griffes des
réformes en cours
monique lubin vous avez une question
justement justement sur les femmes
divorcées en l'occurrence oui sur sur
les pensions de réversion vous avez un
moment envisagé de ne verser la pension
de réversion qu'à compter de l'âge de 62
ans qui a soulevé un tollé et finalement
vous êtes revenu à 55 ans cela dit il
reste une inconnue de taille puisque
nous ne savons pas à l'heure actuelle si
les femmes divorcées pourront bénéficier
d'une pension de reversions à
concurrence égales des années vécues en
commun comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui
or ne pas verser une pension de
reversions aux femmes divorcées ce
serait absolument dramatique parce que
moi je pense notamment aux femmes
victimes de violences dont on parle
beaucoup depuis quelques mois qui se
verrait pour le coup pour un certain
nombre d'entre elles obligées de rester
dans un couple devenu insupportable pour
des raisons de survie à moyen terme
il semblerait que enfin c'est pas il
semblerait ce sont des ordonnances qui
vont prévoir ça ça me chagrine un petit
peu est ce que vous me confirmer que
nous ne discuterons pas de ce point
précis au parlement que vous en
déciderez par ordonnance et qu'elle est
du coup la tendance bon c'est un très
bon sujet malade nationale trice vous
avez et je vous remercie souligné
d'ailleurs que le projet de loi avait
avancé entre leur apport de voix le
projet de loi puisque c'est à 55 ans
vous avez omis de rappeler que c'est son
conditions de ressources d'ailleurs dans
le projet de loi mais je pense que vous
vouliez le dire donc c'est la pension de
reversions ça sera 70% des revenus du
couple au conjoint survivant à partir de
55 ans sans condition de ressources vous
soulignez un point qui est dire que se
passe-t-il en cas de divorce alors qu'à
divorce et au mariage ou c'est qu'il ya
13 systèmes de reversions différente
aujourd'hui
donc c'est très difficile de comparer
les uns les autres calais sous
conditions de ressources pour la source
sous condition d'âge d'autres pas mais
bon on va essayer de répondre à votre
question le plus de son cas possibles
nous avons commandé un rapport à
monsieur fera godard qui était un grand
spécialiste du sujet de manière à
travailler c'est le problème que vous
mettez sur la table et nous attendons
son retour début février
donc tous seront en situation lorsque
nous serons en séance de pouvoir nous
appuyer ce que vous pressez le
changement mais c'est parce que madame
là bas vous d'audition vous demande un
engagement langage a redit l'engagement
que si on a commencé à foncer pour
pouvoir le chef monsieur le ministre
monsieur le ministre je voulais déjà dit
lors d'une question lors d'une séance de
questions au gouvernement
faut-il vraiment attendre un rapport
pour savoir que cette mesure serait
catastrophique pour les femmes divorcées
quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui un mariage
sur deux je sais pas même si c'est pas
encore pire ne se termine pas par un
divorce est ce que vous vous rendez
compte de la portée de cette mesure
jarnac où j'espère que vous me répondez
je comprends que vous n'êtes vous ne
vous n'avez toujours pas décidé de
répondre favorablement à cette demande
la question c'est comment on y répond à
la demande la reverra probablement à 105
100 une opposition jean paul le guen
fait une proposition qui était de dire
ça on le met dans le solde de tout
compte on en matière de déduction
ce soir c'est pour cet intéressant
c'était très intéressant de se dire on a
un éminent spécialiste qui va faire des
propositions de mots clés pour apprendre
ou bien où tu es coup lorsque nous
serons pas besoin de spécialistes
écoutez nous glisse simplement la façon
dont on traite le sujet nécessite comme
de se poser un petit peu fier alors une
autre question précise d'aurélien pradié
sur d'autres situations comme ça parce
que c'est vrai que plus on lit cette
réforme des retraites plus il ya deux
situations particulières c'est très
compliqué de s'y retrouver
mais aurélien pradié une question
précise sur certains parents d'enfants
handicapés
oui au risque de vous irriter je vais
revenir sur du concret est manifestement
le concret vous irrite un peu et donc
j'ai une situation très particulière qui
le concerne pas une la posez votre
question socialisation cette situation
précise ne concerne pas seulement
quelques unités de personnes dans notre
pays
mais près de deux cent cinquante mille
par an qui aujourd'hui élève des enfants
en situation de handicap vous le savez
dans le dispositif actuel ces parents là
bénéficient
de 8 trimestres de bonification parce
que généralement ils s'arrêtent plus
longtemps pour élever leurs enfants les
scolarités sont plus compliquées etc etc
je vous ai déjà posé la question en
vérité je n'ai pas eu les réponses
est-ce que vous pouvez nous garantir que
ces deux cent cinquante mille par an qui
aujourd'hui bénéficient de 8 trimestres
bénéficieront demain du même avantage
les 250 mines dont je parle par ailleurs
comment est-ce qu'on transfère
l'avantagent buis trimestre c'est-à-dire
un avantage de temps dans un système par
points
on ne peut pas le faire de manière aussi
claire puisqu'on ne peut pas compenser
en point ce qui aujourd'hui est d'une
compensation du temps passé pour élever
ses enfants et c'est d'ailleurs la
limite de l'exercice du système par
points chauds et se répondent écoutez
toutes les personnes qui sont en
situation de handicap ont pallié départ
mais j'ai bien et toutes les personnes
qui seront en situation de handicap se
retrouveront dans un système par points
plus simple avec à minima au moins
autant je vous parle d'être davantage je
répond globalement ce qu'on veut la même
chose mais il faut aussi
non mais la situation de handicap avec
un regard global je pense que j'ai tout
d'accord à dire quand vous êtes plutôt
si on n'est pas vrai mais si vous nous
avez laissé fima fera j'aurais déjà et
il répondra deuxième partie voilà direct
donc on a une situation de handicap qui
sera traité dans un système par points à
manille met façon aussi favorable que le
système avait déjà la mc2 mais oui mon
m'a coupé et donc votre votre question
la question c'est celle de la majoration
de durée d'assurance que vous posez
c'est est ce que il y aura les
majorations de durée d'assurance non il
y aura un certain nombre de points qui
seront attribuées au titre de la
solidarité et donc l'engagement du
gouvernement c'est de faire que ces
points au titre de la solidarité soit au
moins aussi chez fanny a avantagé
mentions qu'on pense au moins des
préjudices c'est pour ça qu'il y aura
des points notamment pour les aidants et
les parents qui sont dans une situation
de s'arrêter qui deviennent aidant
bénéficieront de pau au titre de la
solidarité
donc je comprends honnêtement je
comprends votre question ce que chez
votre intérêt sur ce sujet là et la
difficulté qui dira qu'il ya des
majorations de durée d'assurance je vous
dirais honnêtement ce depuis pradier
vous le savez je vous le rappelle que
ces majorations de durée d'assurance à
laval 0 c dans les salles est reporté au
contact 0 permet de compenser les creux
mais par contre à terme est de se
rapprocher du taux évidemment vous
l'un éventuellement ciel oui mais sauf
que votre portion avait calculé que le
montant des salaires qui seront portés
au compte donc sur vous mais des
trimestres à 0 vous n'avez pas de
montant de pension et vous n'avez pas
demain comptoir été donné par là vous
aurez vous aurez des points et donc
c'est sur ces nouvelles que c'est dur
sens et c'est un point important que ces
deux cent cinquante mille familles
toutes les situations
oui mais attendez aujourd'hui c'est nous
mêmes règles pour les 250 d'une famille
vous nous assurez deux mains qu'avec
votre dispositif
ces deux cent cinquante mille familles
bénéficieront des mêmes avantages
je vous assure c'est moi qui est dur à
jouer parce qu'il faudra comparer les
pros et les majorations d'arrivée cela
répondrait différé selon parce que nos
actionnaires
il y aura donc des points qui seront
attribuées au titre de la solidarité
nationale sénat est donc ce sont ces
points qui répondre à votre question est
par ailleurs
bon c'est la réponse en tout cas monique
lubin vous vous dites la réforme des
retraites c'est beaucoup d'histoires
c'est plus de 70 ans d'histoire
on parle aussi beaucoup d'à part du
gouvernement de justice sociale mais
vous y retrouver pas votre compte là
dedans
non non parce que je n'arrive pas à
comprendre comment on peut me parler de
justice sociale dès lors que je vous ai
entendu vous en avez un petit peu parlé
tout à l'heure
dès lors que une pension de retraite
sera calculée sur toute une durée sur 43
ans éventuellement voir plus alors
qu'aujourd'hui elles sont calculées sur
25 ans mathématiquement déjà je ne vois
pas où est la justice sociale et je ne
vois pas sur tout où est la justice
sociale quand on dit quand on ne compte
quand on a fait reculer les critères de
pénibilité que nous avions mis en place
je ne vois pas où est la justice sociale
quand quand on sait qu'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui qu'un cadre et un ouvrier
ont entre cinq et sept ans d'espérance
de vie à la retraite quand on sait
qu'entre les plus pauvres et les plus
riches
il peut y avoir jusqu'à 13 ans de
différence d'espérance de vie
tout cela n'est pas pris en compte dans
le projet de loi en tout cas moi je ne
l'ait pas vu comment peut-on parler de
justice sociale je trouve sincèrement
que de dire un euro cotisé égal 1 point
et tout le monde sera logé à la même
enseigne
c'est simpliste permettez moi de vous
dire c'est simpliste pour moi la justice
sociale c'est quand on permettra aux
gens de compte et non pas seulement leur
retraite
en poèmes et en argent mais de les
compter en temps parce que le temps
qu'il reste à vivre en bonne santé
monsieur l'on laisse c'est un critère
particulièrement important rempli de
sagesse y répondre c'est vrai qu'il ya
on peut se poser la question sans
paroles d'espérance de vie je vais vous
répondre sur la pénibilité puis ça fera
bien que l'espérance de vie sur la
pénibilité
vous avez souligné qu'il existait avant
un système qui s'appelait c3po revenir
sur les détails et qui d'ailleurs ne
fonctionné pas et c'est la réalité
objective mais c'était de rester
objectif
donc nous avons mis en place nos puces
je pense que sur le fond encore une fois
je pense qu'ici tout le monde entre la
table peut être la conscience du fait
que la pénibilité
ça mérite d'être reconnue donc la
question c'est que ça fonctionne réponse
courant qu est ce qui est bien pour que
ça fonctionne aujourd'hui on a six
critères qui fonctionne trois qui sont
liées à l'environnement de travail iii
qui sont liées au rythme de travail
les critères que vous avez évoquées nous
tombons ce qu'on appelle des critères
posturaux 1 qui peuvent impacter la
santé ils ont été transférés au tableau
des accidents du travail et maladies
professionnelles il permet de partir en
retraite à 60 ans à taux plein
aujourd'hui comme il le père comme les
trous de le faire demain mais je sais ce
qu'on peut capacités c'est à dire tant
les gens seront déjà malade
bien sûr c'était extraordinaire et c'est
pas satisfaisant vous avez raison de le
lire ce n'est pas satisfaisant mais
c'est ce qu'on appelle la réparation
nous proposons et ça c'est l'objet des
concertations qui lie avec muriel
pénicaud nous proposons de passer à la
prévention et à la réorientation
professionnelle et ça je pense que ce
sera de l'intérêt de se dire moi je peux
disposer d'un capital pour changer de
job et pour ne plus être dans des
activités 15 et aurélien pradié sur les
régimes spéciaux
vous vous prétendez monsieur le ministre
mettre fin aux régimes spéciaux c'est un
nouveau grand combe a affiché au fond
qu'on prend progressivement que c'est
essentiellement de l'affichage est jeune
donc deux questions très précises à vous
poser si votre réponse peut l'être tout
autant
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire quand
rapide aujourd'hui à quel âge partir à
un steward de 34 ans de mon âge
à quel âge de partir à la retraite est
ce que vous pouvez dire aux français
aujourd'hui à quel âge partir à la
retraite
un choriste de l'opéra de paris est-ce
que vous pouvez nous dire aujourd'hui à
quel âge partir à la retraite
un contrôleur aérien qui commencerait sa
carrière sur ses trois métiers l'âge et
par projets soient ses trois as quel âge
et par poste vous pose la question mais
vous savez pas vous pose la question
fameux suppression des régimes spéciaux
que vous avez annoncé si c'est un puisse
vous avec nous aussi en difficulté vous
que nos questions ça dit tout simplement
avec votre nouvelle organisation sur ses
trois métiers à quel âge quand il
partira l'oreille je pense qu'on peut à
quel âge plutôt parler à quel âge ils
partent à la retraite aujourd'hui on ne
part pas au méga l'âge que les acquis et
l'agefiph en deux parties aujourd'hui le
régime bien sûr qu'ils ont préparé de
questions et vous connaissez mais c'est
aujourd'hui que sont toujours loin dans
l'aventuré s'annonce message aujourd'hui
les réserves sont aujourd'hui dans des
régimes spéciaux est spécifique et donc
qui part entre 55 et 65 de main de
maître avec avec votre prétendue votre
prétendue suppression des régimes
spéciaux fait de l'âge marque-t-il qui a
beaucoup parlé de son parti n'ont
évidemment ça vous kursaal nous étions
capables de répondre parce que la vérité
c'est que nous ne m'étais pas fait
écouter cela répondez moi pour le faire
leur rnb le sérieux qu'on vous dit le
contrôleur est rien l'écoutera kahn
ajoute aériens font partie des profits
demain pour le cas avec votre oeil à
bois réforme dont gilbert à quel âge
répond je réponds pas monsieur grenier
si vous voulez la gombe alors arrête des
contrôleurs aériens font partie des
professions où ils peuvent à la fois où
exposer leur vie et je veux dire un
danger ou éventuellement créer un danger
pour autrui et les cauris dans ce cadre
d'art et on répond par les contrats
aériens de télévision là vous vous
convient pas on change alors pour les
contrôles aériens
effectivement et c'est comme important
lorsqu'on est passionné on vole d'avoir
une sécurité d'avoir quelqu'un qui
surveille le volvo vraiment de répondre
sur les oreilles et qu'il le fait en
sécurité c'est pour ça qu'ils ont un
départ anticipé comme les autres et les
brises autres ils sont dans le sait les
commerçants de l'opéra de paris pour les
choristes de l'opéra de paris
ils auront nous avons proposé que tout
cela se fasse à partir des générations
qui vont venir à partir de 2022 pour une
raison simple c'est qu'il faut
construire des parcours professionnels
57 ans qui vont vous mettez un parcours
professionnel
mais si on devait faire mais que le
radier c'est parce que vous êtes déçu de
ne pas l'avoir fait vous même votre faim
la réalité c'est ça ou alors est claire
aurélien pradié merci monique lubin vous
avez dit qu'ils avaient des questions
plus précises et encore merci d'avoir
répondu laurent pit rachesky avec ce que
vous aviez à dire merci en tout cas
d'être venu sur le plateau d'auditions
publiques et j'en profite pour poser une
question qui nous est parvenu
ici sur figaro live une majorité de
français s'opposent à cette réforme
qu'est ce que vous en pensez monsieur
petra chef qui il faut qu'on fasse plus
de temps d'échangé compris avec des
députés qui ne sont pas d'accord avec ce
sujet là pour qu'on puisse poser les
choses parce que la difficulté c'est
qu'on a du mal à aller sur la réalité
des choses où on est dans des cas ultra
concret ultra minimaliste où on est dans
une vision très globale et ce qui
intéresse les français de savoir
concrètement ce cas c'est pour dire on
remercie les parlementaires qui sont
venus ce soir avant d'accueillir yves
thréard du figaro
merci bonsoir yves au soir francis
bonsoir monsieur n'est pas un chef qui
vous écouter très attentivement pendant
plus de 40 minutes 45 minutes et jamais
assez compliqué et je me disais cette
conclusion je me faisais cette
conclusion qui m'a me faire mon
introduction monsieur delevoye pendant
deux ans et demi n'a rien fait on se
demande ce qui s'est passé ou c'était
une très mauvaise idée d'engager cette
réforme c'est quoi la réponse ça c'est
un mot comprend rien donc faudrait
inviter parce que si après quarante cinq
musées n'a rien compris ça veut dire que
j'ai été très très très mauvais sur les
explications que j'avais pas tous à
apporter sans effort non mais vous êtes
là + 40 jours bon merci de faire ce se
souligne et mon ma relative inexpérience
mais sur le fond qu'est-ce qu'a
construit jean paul delevoye il a réussi
avec les partenaires sociaux en 18 mois
à construire les caractéristiques d'un
système universel de retraite quelque
chose qui date de plus de 75 ans dans
notre pays et il réussit à construire
avec un relatif consensus
un système fut en sus il ya eu 60 jours
de deux manifestations
revenons sur la réalité et les
concertations encore une fois je
comprends que vous vouliez me parler de
l'immédiateté mais moi je vous parle de
ce qui a été construit jusqu'au 18
juillet et on voit bien que la
construction du système futur et bien à
la à générer plus tôt plutôt de
l'adhésion d'ailleurs vous même vous et
vos collègues journalistes vous
60 des français il ya un deuxième temps
et un deuxième nom c'est celui qu'on vit
aujourd'hui c'est celui comme on gère
les transitions oui parce que et comme
angers attention comment on répond à des
situations plus personnel monsieur le
ministre comment on gère les transitions
je veux bien mais vous voulez voter le
texte d'ici à l'été
d'ici à l'été vous allez essayer de nous
monter une usine à gaz
quelque chose qui ne soit pas une usine
à gaz j'ai l'impression en vous écoutant
que bon il ya les danseurs il ya tous
les régimes spéciaux finalement qui sont
très spécifiques des uns les autres
vous avez des cas particulier les femmes
seules les femmes
l'école est d'aider des parents qui ont
des enfants handicapés
comment vous allez arriver à mettre tout
ça en musique pour que et bien
finalement ça soit de réforme plus juste
qui était l'objectif de départ et plus
on avance plus on se dit eh bien c'est
annie injustice cette réforme
moi je lis parfois dans la presse y
compris dans des journaux puis
spécialisés en matière économique ou
même quand j'écoute des grandes radios
périphériques nationale représentant des
confrères avouent qu'ils disent en fait
en regardant l'étude de l'impact
on voit bien que c'est un système plus
redistributif c'est incontestable et sur
le fond il va bien y avoir beaucoup plus
de solidarité vers les futurs retraités
les plus vulnérables enfin la serre
connues y compris d'ailleurs par des
journalistes économiques sont pas
forcément des grands défenseurs de 2 du
projet mais qui jouit c'est
incontestable ça va bénéficier au caire
annoncé pas leur point de vue son nom
c'est ils reprennent les éléments de
l'étude d'un passé ils disent voilà ce
qu'on voit donc donc c'est une réalité
donc sans doute que nous avons peut-être
sur la globalité de la réforme
peut-être réussi à faire passer en tout
cas notre volonté auprès de nos
concitoyens mais nous avons encore
clairement du travail sur les réponses à
des situations plus personnel alors je
reprend l'argument mais mes confrères
qui estime que c'est plus redistributif
ça veut dire que c'est une réforme de
gauche c'est une réforme de justice
sociale il frère ça d'occidentaux
c'est pourquoi d'abord c'est une réforme
de gauche mais je suis moi j'ai pas fais
compagne ça en disant je suis agossou je
suis à droite moshe fait campagne en
disant justement la société civile elle
vient elle vient en responsabilité parce
que justement on commence en avoir un
petit peu assez de leysin versus les
autres
c'est ni à gauche ni à droite et la
question c'est que les bonnes volontés y
en a partout alors c'est une réforme de
justice sociale effectivement nous
portons la justice sociale et la
solidarité donc ce projet est ce que ça
va pas finalement polluer les élections
municipales et ça va pas vous allez pas
payé un lourd tribut à la difficulté de
faire passer cette réforme je crois pas
parce que la signature politique de la
majorité présidentielle la république en
marche modem c'est une signature
réformiste on est là pour réformer
moi j'ai été élu pour réformer moi
j'avais un job avant notre ère
j'aurais sans doute un job après ma
mission moi je suis venu pour réformer
tous les députés la majorité
présidentielle sont venus pour réformer
sont pas venus pour réformer pour mettre
les français entendent sous ou les uns
contre les autres
simplement parce qu' il est temps alors
il est temps de reconstruire cette
solidarité inter générationnelle et
malheureusement vous l'avez vu il ya eu
de la violence mais même dans bien des
airs salle il ya eu des âges et les
jaunes mais dans ce conflit social il ya
eu de la violence
monsieur castaner a élevé le ton et a
même pris des décisions pour retirer
certains modes de justement d'action de
la police ces dernières heures
est ce que le gouvernement a été promu
est là dessus sur le maintien de l'ordre
je dirais qui s'est fait de façon un peu
car gérer ça c'est votre avis qu'un cas
j'entends vous l'exprimez les deux
hommes bon moi je pense qu'il faut dire
les choses ces jeux et oui moi dans mon
équipe
armentières des gens qui sont proches de
moi et qui font partie des forces de
police quand je vais sur le fond dans
cette commune aussi discuter boire un
verre je rencontre aussi des landes et
du commissariat mais il faut reconnaître
d'abord que nos forces de l'ordre elles
sont valeureuse elles sont attentives à
faire quoi vous récusez le dg policière
bien sûr elles font quoi les forces de
l'ordre elle protège l'ordre public à le
protéger citoyens c'est leur première
mission il était temps qu'ils sont là
pour démentir
est-ce qu'il ya est ce qu'il y a une
ligne politique du gouvernement qui vise
à déclencher des violences
bien sûr que non est ce que c'est que ce
terme de violence politique
mais est ce qu'il y a des comportements
est ce qu'il y a eu des comportements
qui doivent être examinées et sur lequel
on doit prendre des sanctions si c'est
confirmé
bah écoutez c'est comme dans tout corps
constitués lorsqu'il ya des quelque
chose qui dysfonctionnent lorsqu'elle
des comportements qui sont inacceptables
ils doivent être sanctionnés il n'y a
pas de débat sur ce sujet là alors bon
excès aux élections municipales puisque
on y revient est ce que vous serez
candidat vous il ya déjà neuf ministres
ou des ministres aujourd'hui il à
l'heure qu'il est qu'ils sont candidats
donc j'ai répondu on a appris que
monsieur darmana d'être candidat tête de
liste à quoi j'irai dharma n'a jamais
caché qu'ils seraient candidats ministre
a évoqué les rues non mais j'ai déjà
répondu à ce sujet l'âge où il ya très
franchement il ya beaucoup de travail
sur ce dossier aujourd'hui elle est
aujourd'hui à ce qu'il faut je reste
concentré et disponible sur ce sujet là
est géré et d très franchement on verra
à chaque fois que c'est nécessaire utile
à biarritz il ya deux ministres qui se
font face
comment vous expliquez ça vous condamnez
bouge pas condamné mais collègue
monsieur les verts le regrettait ce
matin écoutez on perd voilà bah moi je
je je constate comme vous qu'il ya
effectivement une tête de liste est
ensuite un ménisque et dans une autre
liste bon voilà je pense que c'est des
décisions qui sont là on en prend acte
question de ne pas s'en satisfaire on
aimerait qu'il ya une dynamique
collective vous savez moi moi je je je
fais pas de la politique parce que je
suis en train à 20 ans dans un parti
parce que j'ai gravi tous les échelons
du parti parce que j'étais coup il est
là pour réformer un nom mais je suis là
pour porter
la parole des citoyens qui veulent que
leur pays se transforme et avance et
donc je pour assembler les marcheurs
partout ils sont à biarritz comme
ailleurs d'accord alors avant que vous
soyez secrétaire d'état vous étiez sur
les bancs de l'assemblée avec un de vos
pairs qui s'appelle cédric villani qui a
décidé lui de maintenir sa candidature
en dépit d'une jeudi raid table
avertissements du président de la
république et cédric villani bien
maintenant il risque d'être exclu du
parti de la république en marche
vous regrettez cette exclusion d'abord
on verra ce que décidera de bureaux
normalement at on besoin de moi je fais
pas je fais pas partie du bureau
exécutif il ya un mouvement il prend il
prendra sa décision le bureau exécutif
du mouvement
je vous souhaite pas m'exprimer je vais
m'exprimer vous poser la question sur ce
qui va être exclue ou pacsés d'abord un
petit j'en sais rien je vais pas je fais
pas partie du bureau vous vous êtes au
bureau exécutif le message des expos
c'est à paris comme vous l'avez dit tout
à l'heure à biarritz ou ailleurs moi je
pense qu'il faut un très large pas
seulement pourquoi part il faut un très
large choix de ses cerveaux tard parce
que très franchement ou genton et frère
je peux page pas de lui dire que ça
aurait pas dû être fait avant je écouter
la fin observateur de la vie politique
au final est ce que on veut que cette
ville de paris est un autre projet est
ce qu'on veut que sur le fond on soit
peut être plus à l'écouté que le
participatif ça soit pas qu'un bon mot
mais que ça se concrétise par des
avancées réelles
je crois que et cédric villani et
benjamin griveaux ou envie de cela ils
ont envie que les parisiens et les
parisiennes soit là car écouter ci ont
cru en moi je peux contribuer à ce que
cette dynamique soit demain une
dynamique collective
je le ferai bien volontiers à vous à
l'ailé alors vous allez peut-être
téléphoné pour lui dire de toi à moi je
n'aime pas ces jours ci je peux si je
peux aider vous avez ce réunion vol
bien sûr si je peux aider à cette
réunion de ces deux personnalités
importantes est imminente du mouvement
je le ferai bien au dessus merci il au
moins
merci monsieur vous allez faire
l'ambassadeur entre les deux prétendants
de la république en marchant feriana qui
est officiel qui est benjamin griveaux
on le répète
merci merci c'est la fin de votre
audition publique au remplissage skis
merci d'avoir accepté de débattre ne
répond à nos questions aussi ça va vite
quand même une heure mais on peut dire
des choses oubliez pas que vous pouvez
retrouver cette émission sur figaro live
ainsi que sur les comptes twitter de lcp
assemblée nationale public sénat
audition publique se termine pour cette
semaine est pour ce soir et nous
revenons au lundi prochain à 19h bonne
soirée
[Musique]